at first glance not much has changed
photovoltaics still arrive to be
assembled into solar modules and sold
there is no sign of any Chinese here and
management is still entirely German and
it looks as if it will be staying that
way for the foreseeable future that's
the great thing about working with the
Chinese
they're extremely results-oriented that
means they have faith in us in the
management and also in the workers and
as long as we keep the numbers right
nobody is going to interfere it's only
been 3 months since the Conner Jie plant
in Frankfurt Oda was bought by astrology
a subsidiary of the Chinese industrial
group tint astrology products have just
been officially certified as meeting
Chinese standards Qin stepped in at the
last minute to buy the insolvent company
saving the jobs of 200 employees at the
plant why should it matter if they're
German or Chinese the important thing is
that production goes on and we keep our
jobs
astrology panels all carry a made and
Germany label that way Qin avoids EU
import tariffs and with chintz resources
the german based firm can now compete
globally my production side was always
good as was the quality and design of
the product the problems lay elsewhere
but now thanks to the synergies with a
strong financial backing the ability to
source cheaper materials and a customer
network behind us this company has more
options to survive on the market
astrology's Frankfurt auto plant is now
running at full capacity with
round-the-clock production management
hopes that the Qin troops investment
here is just a start I believe they're
looking to become a lot stronger
the Chinese recognize that in the final
analysis they have to produce where
their export markets are so from here
the Qin troop is looking to establish
itself in other regions
for instance the Eastern European market
that's reassuring for frankfurt oda a
city located right on the border with
poland that's in dire need of more jobs
and infrastructure